[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: Hi.
Welcome to our new
series of videos
that will bring you news and
best practices for Actions
on Google.
I'm Ido Green, a developer
advocate for Actions on Google.
I love to help
entrepreneurs and developers
to be more productive.
And in this video,
we are going to learn
how to make sure your apps
for the Google Assistant
will pass the review process.
After you design conversation
and develop apps,
you're probably ready to
share them with users.
Before you make your app
available to the Google
Assistant users, let's see
how to prepare for deployment.
When you submit your
app for approval,
Google tests and
verify that they
meet the minimal set of
[INAUDIBLE] requirements
before publishing them to users.
Let's focus on the
top three pitfalls
you need to avoid in order
to pass the review process.
One, incomplete
store listing data.
Two, naming, directory
listing, and pronunciation.
Three, no response and no lead.
Let's dive into
each of these issues
and see how you could get
your app through the review
process for the first time.
Incomplete store listing data
when submitting for review.
You could see in the
image on the right what
are the top missing parts.
It's the app name,
pronunciation,
picking a name with a
recognizable pronunciation
is critical.
Invocation, how the
user will call your app.
For example, OK Google,
talk to Bitcoin Info.
Please make sure that the
images are in high quality
and that the app
description is accurate.
The large banner image
should be 1920 by 1080.
And the small square
should be 192 by 192.
Another important part
is your privacy policy.
We frequently see example.com
for the privacy policy, which,
of course, is not good.
It must be public, on the
web, and related to your app.
If you don't have a website
you could create one for free
with Google Sites
or other services.
Here is one that I've
created for our assistant app
Bitcoin Info, naming directory
listing and pronunciation.
All apps must have
a unique name that
will allow users to trigger
the app functionality.
Your directory listing must
have at least one sample
of invocation, all of which
must include your app name--
for example, "talk
to Bitcoin Info"--
which consistently
trigger your app.
A few important things
to remember about names--
one-word names are not
allowed unless the name
is unique to your
brand or trademark.
An app name uniquely
identifies your app.
So it must distinguish
itself from other apps
and for features
of the assistant.
You should avoid
very common phrases
like thank you, good
evening, or oh my god.
And don't use generic
words or phrases
such as categories of
products, services, or content.
For example, travel or sport.
Think of it this way.
If your name can describe
a category of apps
rather than a specific function,
change it to be more specific.
Some words and phrases are
reserved and cannot be used
in names, including OK, Google,
volume, up, down, game, bot,
action, and app.
For example, "talk
to Bitcoin Info"
is a good one because
it's specific enough.
And "talk to Bitcoin" or
"talk to Cryptocurrency"
is not good because it's
describing a category and not
a specific action.
You could test your name in
Actions on Google console
to confirm it doesn't use
a reserve word or phrase.
Also double-check that
your display and invocation
name match.
That doesn't mean that
they match verbatim,
but rather match
in pronunciation.
This invocation name
is what is actually
listened for by the assistant.
Always respond and lead.
Don't leave the mic open
without an audio cue.
You want to give the
users an easy way
to move forward with
the conversation
and reach their goal.
That was it.
Good luck.
You can read more about our
review process in the links
below.
Thanks for watching.
We love your feedback, so
please don't be a stranger,
and leave us comments below.
Until next time, be strong
and create amazing apps.